hello heroes of overwatch the team has
been making great progress on the
development overwatch 2.
daily play tests and feedback have given
us confidence that we're creating
something you're going to love at the
same time we want to get the game in
your hand soon which leads to why i'm
here today
but before i get to that
i want to thank our players for your
continued support we recognize we
haven't communicated well haven't kept
you up to date
and honestly we've let you down when it
comes to delivering overwatch content
we hear you and we're committed to more
continual updates on all things
overwatch too this starts with my update
to you today
based on your feedback we've taken some
time to rethink overwatch 2 with the
singular goal of ensuring it is a living
game serving our players with exciting
content on a regular basis
and we are shifting our plan for
overwatch 2 to enable you to play it
sooner
this starts with us decoupling the pvp
features of the game from the pve
systems so we can bring you pvp sooner
this includes the new 5v5 team format
new heroes new maps the new push game
mode
significant hero updates and reworks and
many new gameplay features including for
example a new ping system
when you put it all together this
represents the most new content we have
brought to our game since launch
let me take a moment to share how we got
here a few years ago we made the call to
focus our team's development efforts
almost entirely on overwatch 2.
and as development of the sequel
stretched on it meant that the live game
received
less focus it meant that we were no
longer delivering on one of our core
values to support our game by updating
it and delivering content on a regular
basis
today's change in approach enables us to
deliver frequent pvp content to the live
game with the goal of far exceeding
overwatch's previous rate of content
release and making the live game the
most vibrant and dynamic pvp experience
anywhere in that spirit i'd like to
share that we are beginning over watch 2
pvp testing this week with a closed
alpha containing many of these pvp
features as well as a new hero sojourn
the alpha will be run under nda and be
limited to blizzard employees and key
partners like overwatch league pros as
they get ready for the next season
i'm also excited to announce that we
will be opening the first closed pvp
beta in late april so we can start
testing this content with more players
if you're interested in participating in
this upcoming beta please visit
playoverwatch.com
following that first beta test we are
planning additional public pvp beta
testing later in the year which will
include new features new maps and yes
new heroes
i want to come back to how we started
this conversation improving our
communication to all of you we know you
are eager for more information
as i stated earlier starting now we will
be communicating much more frequently
about our plans
during and after each beta we'll share
updates about what we're learning
changes we're considering and what we'll
look to test next
we look forward to working with you to
make overwatch 2 amazing together
this is going to be an exciting year for
overwatch and we're looking forward to
taking this journey together thank you
for your dedication your passion
and your patience
i can't wait to see players in our alpha
and future beta builds and of course the
entire team can't wait to get overwatch
2 in your hands
thanks for watching be good to each
other
and we'll talk soon